élèves de primaires collégiens lycéens
mais aussi adultes stylo en main testent
leur niveau d'orthographe
avec cette dictée pour tous le thème de
cette année la citoyenneté
il ya une vingtaine trentaine de jeunes
en situation de handicap qui sont là où
qui vont faire la dictée avec leurs
accompagnateurs avec leurs parents ces
salons nous dicter sur la citoyenneté
avec un public extrêmement divers et
variés c'est tout simplement ça le
vivant sans qu'à résister sur la
citoyenneté
liberté égalité fraternité dans un
moment où personne semble personnes
ensemble à ce niveau je suis là au fco
maïtena biraben et gad elmaleh ont lu
cette dictée pour tous devant mille
jeunes venus parfois de loin sans même
faire des blagues ma réaction à ces mots
là va être assez naturel il ya des mots
je veux pas les dévoiler tout de suite
mais il ya des mots qui prête à rire et
qui prête à aller à la perplexité
parmi les pièges de cette dictée olic
idyllique ou encore le terme honni
coffrage à la difficile elle difficile
et
après c'est un enjeu personnel parce que
j'ai faits littéraires si je fais des
fautes la cgt aurait vécu il ya des mots
que je ne connais pas donc j'essaye
d'appréhender composant un petit peu la
racine d'essayer de retrouver
l'orthographe la dictée pour tous créé
par abdellah boudour a vu le jour en
2013 sur la dalle d'argenteuil 237
dicter au compteur plus tard c'est au
château de versailles à la galerie des
batailles que le rendez vous a eu lieu
on a du mal avec la barrière de la
langue française martèle maps et là le
fait qu'il ya de grandes personnalités
s'associent dans le symbole eh bah ça
fait que tout le monde a évolué il ya
vraiment un engouement et j'espère que
ces familles là et ces associations de
personnes ils vont garder ce souvenir
prochain objectif faire cette dictée
pour tous dans un autre lieu
emblématique à la tour eiffel